what should you do if you want to be
very successful and have a very very big
impact on the world make your work and
your passion the same thing and don't
forget about the money part but do it in
a way that you're going to uh produce
enough money that you're going to be
able to have the resources to have a big
impact on the world I always think about
how my actions align with my principles
and if they uh don't align I either have
to bring my actions in line with my
principles or my principles in line with
my actions how do you know if a mentor
is good for you really it's quite simple
do you have sympatico with that me
mentor and are you learning a lot how do
you approach the work life balance the
key is to get more out of a day if you
can get more out of a day uh by
leveraging yourself in a number of ways
you will get more life into a day how
can we lift up the entire uh Global Comm
community just be good with each other
if you are generous and you think of the
common good and so on we would have a
wonderful um Society um that's what we
that's all we need to do